get forward standing six foot two inches
[Applause]
[Music]
how long they've been doing that that's
three or four games weird right yeah I
can see I hate it
a kid he had a good game where's he
going to college oh he's coming to work
for us a family business construction
I'm a scout if you want me to make a few
phone calls there might be a hole here
or there some of those polls have
scholarships
no that's 20 years ago I told him we
should use uh ain't gonna be no rematch
at the end of Rocky that's 40 years ago
was this sticks oh this is Danny nice to
meet you yeah do not like her don't be
mean in front of her she don't know us
yet come to dinner Sunday 12 o'clock
dinner at 12. I love it I'll be there
[Music]
from Forest Hills we worked on a house
over there guy at Maserati oh yeah but
it was yellow no thanks any more
meatballs oh I'll make us some more oh
no no Neighbors
he gets on that team everything changes
for him you need to turn down the raw
Rock what I'm excited just let it be his
choice
she broke up with me I'm so surprised
your mom's hysterical because she
doesn't like seeing you like this she's
getting hurt
[Music]
he'll be okay I just gotta get his mind
off it you know get him back on the
court
hey Danny he's not going to make that
team if he said like this maybe you
could go bug out with him like the pine
trees line in the winding road Leo what
did you do you humiliated him I'm trying
to save him from a lifetime of
humiliation
[Music]
I always try to do what I think is best
for you
do your lucky sticks have family that
cares that much
[Music]
column sticks because of the long legs
came out of the chute that way just kept
growing
still growing
really
came out of my shoot